there's another issue out there that
isn't getting discussed like it should
we just assumed it would improve this
year rod graves who is the executive
director of the fritz pollard alliance
issued a statement overnight regarding
the fact that the five coaches hired so
far
there isn't a single black coach who's
been employed
and here's the quote the key quote from
the statement that was issued by rod
graves the disparity in opportunities
is mind-boggling it's unfortunate for
performances of coordinators like eric b
enemy todd bowles byron leftwich
leslie frazier and joe woods may not
meet what appears as
ever evolving standards for becoming a
black head coach in the nfl
the prospect for second chances is
proving to be even more elusive
the same applies to executives like
jerry reese rick smith reggie mckenzie
and others
all capable of providing the vision
leadership and expertise
to lead a championship effort so
um you know they they
they keep trying the lead and the league
office
is trying i know they are they're trying
i know but
but you've got not 32 monarchies running
the nfl teams but close to it you can't
tell them what to do you can't force
them what to do
and it's the threat of litigation that
caused the rooney rule to be adopted a
generation ago
and it may be the reality of litigation
that ultimately
gets one of these owners to realize
holy crap we do have to do a better job
here it isn't my way or the highway
i don't get to say and do whatever i
want there are laws out there
that require me to afford
equal employment opportunity and the
numbers
regardless of any testimony that would
come out right
any secret donald sterling tape like
that you're not going to have that
what you're going to have is numbers and
the numbers aren't good for the nfl
right now they weren't good
in 2002 chris and they're not good now
no they're not good
you know and i i mean i i believe you i
know the nfl they want change here
they're trying to do their best to force
the issue here as well
it's not going to happen overnight it is
unfair it's screwed over
it's the nfl is
deep rooted in its whiteness sorry for
lack of a better way to say it
but this is a family sport with
coaching staffs that are three and four
generations in
to like my dad coached and my
grandfather coached and that's why i'm
here coaching in the nfl
and it's hard to get out of that cycle
there
that's the biggest problem so there's
familiarity between
a lot of these people in the nfl oh i
know that guy i've known him since he
was little i'm gonna hire him
and that is the issue more than anything
let alone like we've talked about before
mike
it's hard to get in the building unless
you know somebody as is
and that's an issue too and you have to
have some money in the bank saved up
because you're going to make no money
once you get started in the league
that's the key it's nepotism which runs
rampant among coaching circles in the
nfl so if you have white coaches
you're going to have white children
taking the jobs
at the lower levels who you know who who
you move in the same circles with that's
part of it and like you said
those entry level jobs you better have
somebody else who is financing your
lifestyle
paying your rent buying your food
because you aren't going to make
jack squats nothing why i don't understa
i understand it's a low minimum wage
proving ground
it shows how much you love football if
you allow yourself to work for free
why can't the entry-level jobs provide a
living wage
so anyone can take them not just the
people who otherwise have money
it's offensive when you think about it
that way it is it's that's the biggest
problem to me
being involved in it as a player seeing
it a little bit in the front office
there with the new england patriots and
all that
it is that's where it's really got to
change
is that aspect it's deep rooted into the
league and it's going to be hard to get
it rooted out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports